[Música]
momento de hablar de ciencia y
tecnología en France 24 soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
en el espacio porque china lanzó el
último de los módulos clave de su
estación thian con el que se completa La
Estructura central se llama mentyán que
significa sueño de los cielos y se
acopló adecuadamente tras 13 horas tiene
una longitud de 17,8 metros y un
diámetro de 4,2 metros su peso en la
tierra era de alrededor de 23 toneladas
y es un área exclusiva para trabajo y
actividad deportiva es decir que no
cuenta con baños y dormitorios como los
otros dos módulos el tiange y el buen
tian este tercero el mentyán tampoco
está equipado con sistemas de soporte
vital regenerativo como los otros dos
por lo que deja más espacio a los
tyconautas para experimentos científicos
creo que el módulo de laboratorio
mentían es bastante especial ya que es
un módulo solo para experimentos que
puede verse como un estudio
especializado hay 13 bastidores de
experimentos científicos adentro y 37
estaciones de carga expuestas afuera lo
que permitirá a los taiconautas a hacer
más experimentos de carga extravehicular
en el futuro
recordemos que la actuación tiangoon
está diseñada para tener forma de té y
actualmente hay tres taconautas en la
instalación que son los encargados de
finalizar los trabajos pertinentes para
que quede operativa expertos aseguran
que este paso de Beijing es clave en el
espacio porque pone a China en igualdad
de condiciones con Estados Unidos Europa
y Rusia
cambiamos de tema pero seguimos en el
espacio porque la NASA reveló la imagen
de un cráter gigante producido por el
impacto de un meteorito en Marte se
trata de un hecho que ocurrió el 24 de
diciembre de 2021 y que fue detectado
por la Sonda inside
en diciembre del año pasado un meteorito
golpeó Marte y creó el cráter de impacto
fresco más grande que hemos observado en
16 años de la misión mro sin years of
Mission
What have la capacidad de decir que
sucedió cuando Y qué actividad ocurrió
junto con el cráter de impacto más
grande
son dos grandes descubrimientos y
demuestran el valor aumentado que aporta
el trabajo conjunto de dos misiones
las ondas sísmicas causadas por el
choque viajaron por la superficie del
planeta y fueron recogidas por el
sismómetro de inside contrario a lo que
ocurre en nuestro planeta las ondas
sísmicas en Marte permiten cartografiar
el planeta cuando las ondas son
profundas revelan información sobre el
núcleo y el manto Y si son superficiales
dan datos sobre la corteza justamente
esas ondas superficiales fueron las que
se produjeron Con el impacto del
meteorito
a partir de esta imagen de Gran altura
quedó inmediatamente Claro que este es
el cráter nuevo más grande que jamás
hayamos visto tiene aproximadamente 152
metros de ancho aproximadamente dos
cuadras de una ciudad de ancho y aunque
los meteoritos están golpeando el
planeta todo el tiempo este cráter es 10
veces más grande que los nuevos cráteres
típicos que vemos formándose en Marte lo
más emocionante de todo es que vimos
claramente en imágenes de alta
resolución que una gran cantidad de
hielo de agua quedó expuesto por este
impacto puede ver en este vídeo en 3D
Trozos de hielo del tamaño de una roca
en el cráter eyecciones así como
salpicaduras de hielo arrojadas por la
zona fuera del cráter Esto fue
sorprendente porque este es el lugar más
cálido de Marte el más cercano al
Ecuador Marciano en el que hayamos visto
hielo de agua los responsables del
proyecto ponderan el descubrimiento de
hielo porque una vez que los humanos
vayan al planeta rojo consideran que es
clave tener muy bien identificados los
puntos donde ese hielo es de agua
justamente porque se puede convertir en
agua oxígeno o hidrógeno algo que será
muy útil en las misiones exploratorias
volvemos a la Tierra y vamos a Reino
Unido para conocer la historia de una
niña de 8 años llamada Harmony debido a
una meningitis los médicos tuvieron que
amputar sus piernas y parte de sus
brazos Pues gracias a prótesis
computarizadas de alta tecnología la
menor ya puede caminar y de acuerdo con
las responsables podrá correr y jugar
dentro de poco pues solo le tomó una
semana aprender a usarlas las rodillas
de las prótesis están equipadas con
microprocesadores que reducen el riesgo
de caídas permitiéndole levantarse
sentarse doblar las rodillas y patear
es una niña muy activa creo que la
última medición fue de 2500 pasos por
día lo que para una amputado bilateral
es increíble Así que está sobreviviendo
finalizamos con un tema para Los amantes
de las mascotas muchos dueños usan
tatuajes o chips para identificar a sus
compañeros pero en Corea del Sur la
empresa tecnológica bysidelab
Corporation está usando un registro de
su nariz algo que funciona como la
huella digital de un humano se escanea
la nariz con la cámara de un teléfono
móvil y se envía la aplicación anypop
es una tecnología de reconocimiento
biométrico para los patrones de la nariz
de animales como perros y gatos pero
también para vacas o ciervos
es un algoritmo biométrico 3D que se
basa en Inteligencia artificial y
aprendizaje profundo ahora lo ponemos en
los teléfonos para que puedas tomar la
foto de los patrones de la nariz
identificar a cada animal las
responsables aseguran que se trata de
una tecnología con un 99,9% de precisión
el programa se viene desarrollando desde
2019 en conjunto con el gobierno de
Corea del Sur y estaba planeado que en
unos meses puedo hacer completado para
que sirva como método oficial de
registro de mascotas en el país así
finalizamos este espacio Les agradecemos
su sintonía continúen con nosotros en
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]